hello and welcome to this video
yeah it's been a while since I did some
videos in one of those serious like
endgame strategy middle game strategy
and so on but of course those series
they are not dead it's just like there
were other things to do yeah I did term
the World Championship match I did cover
lots of my own games which is always
some in high demand people like that so
I do coverage of my own games at all so
it's something that I must admit it's
good yeah for my own chess because I
look at my games a little bit more
thoroughly then and to present them on
the channel is a good thing also for me
ma'am like reviewing my mistakes things
like that of course you also do that on
your own when you're not doing a video
but but still it is it gives the new
extra incentive to to do things with
your own video of your own games
okay well back to that serious endgame
strategy this is part 10 and it's quite
funny that in the first nine parts I
never had a game of one of the greatest
endgame strategists of all time of
course I'm talking about the Swedish
living legend or Thunder son who funnily
enough actually played in those two in
this tournament that I played in the
open the variant Championships we played
next to each other two or three times
it's quite quite fun ok so let's have a
look at this game this is a game where
under song played black it's about
endgame strategy but I'm going to go
briefly through the whole game because
we relatively quickly reach an endgame
and it's a good thing to see the
development how it came to the same game
the white player is so Ronaldo Veera is
a grandmaster maybe not at the time 85
quite quite early maybe he was a
grandmaster even back then but decently
high rated about 2500 at the time so
let's have a look wolf of course playing
black and he was and always Slayers an
excellent strategist and positional
player but he's now
really yeah gone away from playing the
Sicilian you're always playing the
Sicilian as black not all the time he
also played his French defenses and so
on but he had lots of sharp Sicilian
this black the T Avira played c3 the
alle pin and understand plays with e6
and d5 that's a very solid answer to the
c3 so yeah and something that can be
recommended if you don't mind
French structures yeah of course white
can go if I for the advanced French I
can take on d5 as Vera did in the game
after which well Queen takes d5 is still
possible but he takes d5 is the true
French move played by ophea and well now
we got an isolated queen pawn position
really quickly after Bishop b3 now under
Sun takes on D form this actually move
that that I like a lot C form it's also
an option here after which something
like b3 leads to an entirely different
poor information but the move here
played in the game the capture I think
is quite interesting the idea is that
after Bishop takes under some place
knight c6 Knight f3 and now he plays the
move a 6 that's actually a move that I
did not know before looking at this game
but it's it's very logical when I played
this is black some years ago I was going
for this actually taking Knight takes
maybe Queen takes is worth considering
and then Bishop c5 the idea being that
after this check I went King f8 let's go
funny funny line but it is quite decent
black is playing Knight f6 g6 and King
g7 which is a good formation on the King
side and often the bishop on b5 is not
so well placed after Queen b6 very often
there is a temporal loss involved on
this Bishop so maybe some interesting
hints here about the opening but ok the
opening is not the main feature of this
game under Sun didn't take he played the
move a 6 the idea is that after this he
took and then
played Knight f6 and Bishop c5 without
having to worry about to check on b5 so
good stuff now Knight f1 yeah white
takes lots of time to regroup his Knight
yeah 93 room p8 castles Queen b6 yeah
I'm not sure about this in I'd maneuver
it puts some pressure on d5 but it is
never really enough to trouble black on
this pawn on the other hand black has
two bishops and an active rook an active
queen so the the main thing that you
need to look for when you have an
isolated cream phone is definitely their
activity like has active pieces rook b1
not a happy move but b2 was hanging and
it there wasn't really a great
alternative Bishop to d7 just developing
Bishop f3 and Bishop c6 yeah black is
covering the pawn and prepares further
centralization however now white went
with before a very direct move
challenging the c5 Bishop yeah
what should black do now yeah black can
retreat and preserve his bishop or I can
take on d4 and what is very remarkable
as said no Allison takes on default I
don't think that Bishop f8 would have
been that terrible by the way but the
capture is just a good move probably the
better move but well the authoritative
was not leading to to trouble or
anything
the remarkable thing is the following
black took Queen takes Queen takes C
takes D form yeah very interesting so
it's a quite simplified position and at
first you might think okay isn't this a
little bit better for wide maybe yeah
why why could this be better for white
yeah white has two pieces attacking the
pawn and it looks like it's only
passively defended which is in some way
to the knight and Bishop they both cover
this pawn so it's a sick classic case
a bad Bishop versus a good Bishop
situation well almost there are some
subtle differences in in this position
or some differences is wrong some subtle
nuances in this position that have to be
M considered it is in fact a very
important point that white has played
the move b2 before if it if this
wouldn't have happened
I mean this is a theoretical discussion
now in a way because before initiated
the structure with Bishop takes and the
trades on d4 but the main point is that
whites Queen side is weakened those
squares are weak c4 b5 a 4 and there are
potential invasion squares for blacks
pieces on the other hand it's not so
easy for white to imagine how to invade
on the C fellow on the e-file especially
in view of blacks coming maneuver black
plays g6 and it should be really viewed
and in connection to this maneuver g6
yeah this is an important move it takes
away the f5 Square from the night
it puts yet another pawn on light
squares note that black has all pawns on
light squares with this bishop being on
a light square as well this is something
that normally shouldn't be done but we
have a case here where this is not
really an issue and this is because this
is not a totally closed position where
this bishop on c6 is just let's say
incarcerated by his own pawns that's not
the case the bishop here all the time
has this option for example to activate
or via B 5 B 5 d3 those kind of things
so it's not it shouldn't be viewed is
totally dogmatic that pawns should be on
the other color not the color of the
bishop but on the other color in some
cases it's not really not really a
problem to have those pawns on the
squares that your bishop is on in fact
sometimes it's a case and I had this in
numerous games owned in
over the board and blitz chess sometimes
you even have the case that in fact
those pawns that are on dark squares
they cannot be protected by the bishop
eeeh White's bishop cannot protect the
pawns on d4 and before and therefore
they tend to be weak rather somewhat
here barely placed pawns are securely
defended by the bishop this is a very
interesting phenomenon sometimes and
chess that this this is funny
finally quote by romanian grandmaster
Shuba not sure if I'm pronouncing it
correctly it's su ba Zuba Zuba i don't
know exactly how he is pronounce it he
has his famous quote like bet bad
bishops protect good points and there is
this is a really a funny quote but there
are cases really rather optically likes
on the surface bad-looking Bishop is not
not really a problem and here there is
one of those cases one key point is the
following
white not played g3y a useful a useful
move that I mean maybe this is an idea a
regrouping the night or even gaining a
little bit of space here on the kingside
it's maybe questionable this wasn't
necessary but it's a kind of a routine
move that very often it's played and now
what black is doing is very instructive
black in fact has some hazards pieces on
good squares the only thing that you can
argue about is to look on ahead
everything else is like well placed the
knight on f6 and the bishop they're
doing their respective jobs so what
should plague do well in the endgame you
need the King and black is doing that
immediately king of eight rooks e1 looks
normal and King e7 heading for d6 yeah
this is really very instructive before
everything else black is activating the
King and once the King arrives on d6 it
accomplishes two very important things
it covers the d5 pawn which is super
important
it lends cover to this pawn a second
time or here even a third time so that
one of the minor pieces and this will be
especially the bishop is free to
maneuver yeah it sort of helps to
activate the other pieces yeah with the
King being a defender of the pawn you
can use the bishop actively for instance
here or somewhere else the King on d6
also we can put this on the board white
played a four relying on the little
tactic and my tactic is a strong word
for that that you regain the podium
after this one doesn't just played king
d6 we can look at this really on the
board now the King is ideally placed
note that with g6 he had prepared this
yeah this was a a deep plan the King on
d6 also covers those crucial squares
where their potential there's potential
for white rook entering the position
this is really an ideal setup from
blacks point of view you're covering
things and also freeing your pieces for
activity like the bishop on c6 white now
played rook a one yeah now a4 was was
hanging as 55 was protected and rook c8
a for maybe slightly question abut it's
not it's not nothing bad is happening to
white yet he went a five fixing pawns on
the light squares 94 centralizing the
snide rooks e2 Bishop d7 all very
logical with Bishop d7 like um intends
to him
yeah activate this piece and maybe trade
one pair of rooks
the Sun can be can be useful device here
to make some progress here we come to an
interesting point in the game white took
the knight on e4 which is a very
tempting move to play because quite
often if you believe that you have the
better minor piece I mean
to put it in complete words if you think
that the opponent has a bad bishop you
very often want a night against the bad
bishop because the knight often is the
the better piece and those clothes type
of position he however after Bishop
takes e4 it's not really a closed
position there's an E and C file open so
Bishop takes e4 is questionable in this
position and sort of leads to the
difficulties that that white is going to
experience black already is a little bit
more comfortable with this King on d6 is
more active with the swords pieces but
if white now finds the best move he's
still very much in the game and has a
balanced position um what is White's
best move here may be treated as a
little exercise if white plays the best
move here he's still okay I'll be silent
for a couple of seconds and then I'll
tell you the move you said to to drink
something yeah white now has an
excellent move to keep the balance and
this is a very strong move rook to c5
it's very strong it activates this rook
a ticking d5 and there well of course
it's not blundering in exchange if black
takes it wide will recapture with the B
pawn with check very nice now and where
should play ko it's not so easy if you
go to c7 for example you run into checks
and this is a very nice way to continue
yeah like rook c7
no idea and this is a funny funny draw
and black really is in no position to to
play for a win here it's it's
exceptionally problematic to to continue
this now let's say I'm after 95 do you
want to go somewhere else yeah okay it's
actually if you go to c8 there is some
amongst others is still not be six year
he might be six I mean this is this is a
very risky decision trying to try to
continue here moves like let's say rook
p1 or 97 and c6 they are very
problematic it's a not a good idea
really to try to continue here rook c5
was a great defensive resource that
however wasn't played by at the white
player he took on e4 it's not impossible
that he thought he's maybe playing for
an advantage I mean it's possible but
this is really really not the case rook
takes you for Lucas e8 Bishop c8 you
know and now we see another problem as I
mentioned this can for these pawns they
are one durable attacked by the rook so
why it has to now take up defensive post
with this rook yeah move like let's say
I'm Knight see - it's not leading to
much black can't just enter with the
rook and this is going to be problematic
note that those entry squares are
covered by the King but the white king
is still on g1 so this is a huge
difference and if you compare both both
camps yeah rook t1 is stronger and it's
not like white is in in super big
trouble he can still put up with great
defense but it gets difficult Bishop d7
yeah eyeing this this Square for
activation or b5 yeah those are good
ways to activate the Bishop rook t2
you're getting out of the possible tempo
with Bishop a4
yeah and now a key position how does
black continue yeah you need to to make
progress it's all good and all nice but
how are you going to progress there are
three basic ideas that black can go for
he can activate his the pieces
like this for example I didn't do that
what was that or you can play Bishop a4
yeah trying to activate this Bishop
another plan is this has to be timed
correctly of course it's the invasion
painting this errors are wrong so the
invasion of the King as I mentioned
there are LightSquared weaknesses with b
4 and a 5 this is a big difference to
let's say if the pawns now if white
pawns were on a 2 and B 2 for example
I'd rather be white in this position
it's nothing great yeah it's not like
white is usually better anything but
it's a huge difference as those pawns if
they were here they really yeah they
weren't there won't be a weakness on the
Queen side then and there's really not
much to play for now it's equal yeah I'd
rather be widest just my net natural
optimism but it's a it's nothing for
white it's it's just equal but this way
with those weaknesses like it's
definitely calling the shots
the third plan and the one played on
doesn't first is the move I think it's
the strongest f5 yeah
gaining space black is intending to push
f4 or g5 and F for gaining further space
or weakening the position of white even
further white now has to react yes -
yeah set up the position for a CAPTCHA
on FYE King G to him and then F for
happened oh yes - to come here for
for example 92 was an idea in fact this
was the movie I actually expected to to
be played but it's not giving white yeah
huge relief as well um black for example
is also g5 but you can also play this
move which is quite interesting the idea
is that black is intending to switch his
attention to the C file or to c3 both
are very worthwhile the one point is
that if now white tries Bishop rook c2
to cover the CFR then black has Bishop
f4 and we see them benefits of having a
long range piece like the bishop this is
just attacked and the rook has to do
both jobs now defending eetu and
defending the C file and I cannot do
both yeah something like rook c3 now is
answered by invasion like on e 2 or you
four maybe even if oh yeah something
like that
for example and now note that here white
is in huge trouble something like the
the trade for example he loses like
immediately because black will invade
with the king the King position on d6 is
just fantastic it's good for defense
covering the seventh rank covering E&C
file but also it's active going through
those weak pawns on the Queen side black
has a clear invasion route so um this
move Knight g2 wouldn't have saved white
as well well this is too strong I mean
in in fact I think what he did was
better but not g2 is is not helping at
all he went King g2 and 491 this is a
tougher defense it looks a bit passive
but the night is coming to c3 so it does
have an idea
rook e1 f3 and now a new ideas
introduced in the position or well not
introduced it is executed black is
entering with the Bishop Bishop a4 with
the tempo on the knight very important
93 and Bishop to b3 yeah note that the
bishop will find an excellent post on c4
it's just more active there than on d7
it covers the d5 pawn potentially covers
a6 in some situations like that say b5
is happening sometime it's just probably
the best possible position for this
Bishop on the board and it clearly shows
that a bad bishop in terms of purely
looking at the
complexes LightSquared bishop when all
pawns on light squares it's not
necessarily a bad piece because if it
gets out of the pawn chain and here
there never was a close pawn chain
anyway if it gets out of the pawn chain
it would be a very active piece that
really I mean it just looks right into
White's position and even yeah it's
helping to dominate the knight 'i'm in
this position i think
weiter miss the chance to defend to
defend much better maybe if you if you
have a look at this position and treat
this as a little exercise what is the
the best way for white to continue to
defend him give you a little time to
pause the video it is not trivial taking
a little bit of time it's a good
exercise in defense yeah I think them
the best defense here I can tell you
what you play baby I can start with that
white played the move on look b2 which
is really not doing that much as some
black is playing Bishop c4 anyway but he
had a good chance here to to activate
his position I think he should have
played the move G for him the idea is
that white wants to go here
King g3 and then look to h2 activating
the look against the h7 point this is
the only weakness in a way that white
can attack and blacks position and you
should definitely try try to do that um
it's not I don't I didn't do and really
an exhaustive analysis he I just want to
show you some key points let's say
Bishop c4 it so if the logical move King
g3 and black let's say plays King to c6
trying to prepare this invasion route
yeah once the knight is going away from
c3 which can easily happen black just
has to attack it in some way and then we
are ready to enter with
yeah and now rook age two going for
counterplay rookie three right a fork in
b5 tonight c5 f king before rue gate
seven King c3 Knight p7 king before g7
it's just this is just a sample line to
illustrate what my point is why does
getting some activity with this rook and
there are chances to to trade off more
pawns I still think that black is
definitely better here with the D pawn
and the better Milan piece but it's
nothing that will be be lost like
quickly the computer in fact only gives
black a very slight advantage where I'm
a little bit in doubt if he would keep
this evaluation if you let it calculate
for a long time and only checked it for
like a minute or something else because
my hunch is that the D pawn in
combination with the bishop is just very
strong but still it's it's a fight in
the game however you see him that whites
position is going downhill really really
quickly instead of the jump back of this
g4 move with this activation he went
Lucca p2 as mentioned and then Bishop c4
and now we are approaching something
like I mean it's not a dukes one but
it's close
white really has problems to move this
pieces and if this Knight is at some
point dislodged from the square there is
this additional thing happening with the
King invading it's now going down let's
mention really quickly why played rugby
one rookie three and now it is really
tricky if you want to move the knight
this only a four and this also doesn't
help that much like Knight a four give
this check King to h3 where else and now
we have this situation the knight is
looking nice but start doing very much
and this is just a weak pawn this is
defended black is going to invade even
further
you know it's really funny that the
light squares are so weak on the white
side and the bishop is not a problem at
all it's just a better piece yeah and
then the knight Knight a4 didn't look
great
so he went rooks e1 but now this is
simple move rook to e3 and that's it
this pawn is gone Knight a4 was played
rookie 495 and we actually arrived to
the at the same position that I showed
before almost the same position rook e1
and rookie - this was move 40 and here
the white player resigned probably after
the time controller was completed yeah
this is now a very easy win for black
you have the extra deep on that we'll
just move forward and additionally you
can always pick up the whole Queen side
with the King that's actually a very
nice example of an undertaker proach to
pawn structure related to the bishop
yeah here Anderson really didn't mind to
put all his pawns on light squares
it wasn't the problem at all that those
pawns were vulnerable or or subject to
an attack in fact due to blacks better
activity at the active rook here and the
ideas to invade with the bishop on those
those routes here it wasn't a problem at
all that he had the pawns on the light
squares in fact um the light squares on
the white side really were weak the key
point was that white had advanced his
Queen side points then that Farb the
board so that there actually were
weaknesses that the black king actually
and at the end really in in the game are
used to invade so a very nice example
that shows sometimes it's not that big a
deal if you put the pawns on the color
complex of the bishop that you have it
depends on the activity of the bishop
can it be activated to actually enter
the opponent's camp and the piece
activity or other pieces this is very
important
um to get a complete picture about the
position it's really about the bishop
and the color of the pawns alone it's
also about what can you do with your
pieces what can you attack and what are
the weaknesses in the opponent's
position yeah I hope you enjoyed this
video there's a really nice example of a
great end game play I hope you enjoyed
it thanks for watching